And maybe I made a mistake yesterday,...
...but yesterday's me is still me.
Today, I am who I am with all of my faults and my mistakes.
Tomorrow, I might be a tiny bit wiser...
...and that would be me too.
These faults and mistakes are what I am,...
...making up the brightest stars in the constellation of my life.
I have come to love myself for who I am...
...for who I was and for who I hope to become.
I'd like to say one last thing.
So let's all take one more step.
We have learned to love ourselves,...
...so I now urge you to speak yourself.
I'd like to ask all of you.
What is your name?
What excites you and makes your heart beat?
Tell me your story.
I want to hear your voice and I want to hear your conviction.
No matter who you are, where you're from...
...your skin color, your gender identity, just speak yourself.
Find your name and find your voice by speaking yourself.
I'm Kim Nam Jun and also RM of BTS.
I'm an idol and I'm an artist from a small town in Korea.
Like most people, I've made many and plenty mistakes in my life.
I have many faults and I have many more fears,...
...but I'm going to embrace myself as hard as I can,...
...and I'm starting to love myself, gradually, just little by little.